the founder and executive chairman of
fanatics michael rubin kicking off this
hour how are you giving me new
opportunities let's go
[Laughter]
you know commissioner you know what's
missing from that law from that is the
fanatics logo you can make one of these
right if you need to i mean i think it's
pretty special as it is but we'd be
happy to add the financial logo to and
uh just more to it
so um
how how did how did you start this what
did walk me through the beginning of you
now
building what is uh a behemoth in
fanatics well actually we don't think of
ourselves that way at all we honestly
still think we're in the early days of
the business okay and we're just getting
going we really feel that way that's
just not like some elevator line i look
every day and say we have uh so much
opportunity ahead of us i think we're
you know early in the first quarter of
the game and i think we've got so much
more to do in the future but you know
for me um you just talked about hall of
famers yeah that was not me i was like
the world's worst athlete i was equally
bad a student where'd you grow up i grew
up in philly okay and uh this is okay
yeah and and uh there was only one thing
i was good i was working like i loved
work and i loved business and so i
started as an entrepreneur like
literally as a kid and you know eight
ten years old and you're just always
selling different things and so i you
know my first real company was a company
called gsi commerce that ebay bought in
2011 for two and a half billion dollars
when they bought the company um
they there was a business called
fanatics which was a teeny business and
it owned inventory it wasn't something
they were interested in so we bought it
back it was only about a 250 million
dollar business then and really was not
very differentiated not very special and
so i really started with the business in
2011 that's when i became 100 locked in
and focused on how do we build the best
experience for the fan how do we really
globalize this business how do we
verticalize this business how do we just
you know uplevel everything we're doing
for the fan and it's been great we've
been at it for 10 years and uh you know
i think i'll be doing this in another 30
or 40 years so long as if i'm on this
planet i'm going to be doing this well
when did you first knock on the nfl's
door or vice versa it's actually a great
story so i did that as part of my own
company that ebay bought i started
approaching the nfl probably in 2001
2002 there was a uh a sushi place called
hero that was in the building of uh and
i found i think i probably had 200 her
meals at heru before i actually uh won
the business with the nfl and got in
business with nfl so my sushi intake my
mercury is very high just from trying to
to to win the nfl's business and
literally started on the ground floor
started on the ground floor for sure
yeah at a restaurant yeah i i still
remember what i ordered every time when
i went there so yeah so i probably we i
think we got in business with nfl in
2006 but we started pitching them in
1999 when i started gsi commerce so it
was probably a seven-year um you know
kind of cycle to get in business
together but they've been incredible
partners the nfl's um you know business
has grown tremendously uh while we've
been together and what's been great is
you know we're always thinking about how
do we improve the fan experience how do
we you know grow our assortment how do
we innovate and you know i think you
know both business has kind of grown
together it's been it's been a lot of
fun so far so how do you with the nfl i
mean yeah
how does one innovate with the nfl
because you know change sometimes with
the national football league is is uh
takes a while yeah well you know for us
look we're a super aggressive
entrepreneurial company that's always
thinking about like how do you do what's
best for the fan how do you innovate and
like at the end of the day we carry a
million and a half skus in our original
business so today finance is much bigger
than the merchandise business where we
start we call that finance commerce and
right and and that business day has a
million and a half skus that sports fans
globally buy and that's if you think
about the complexity you know one year
the bengals aren't so good the next year
than the super ball and um you know
that's what's amazing about our our
business we can have a team that's you
know the 32nd team in the league one
year and they could be the best team in
the league for the tampa bay bucks were
probably one of the the least performing
teams before brady got to tempe and you
know a year later they were number one
team in the nfl so we deal with you know
really big assort assortments we keep
creating new products growing the market
bringing new brands into the nfl and you
kind of joked about um all the different
different products we sell but we also
work with 150 incredible vendors that we
buy from so that's what makes up the
million they have skus that makes fnatic
so special in the merchandise business
what's interesting today yes is that
we're really evolving the business where
we started in the merchandise business
originally now in the trading cards
business when the nft business uh we're
getting into the online sports betting i
gaming business um we we we're an
investor in lids the retail business so
i think we think about the future for
fanatics as how do we have billions of
fans globally the look of fidax is a
beloved brand they get all the digital
sports needs from us so how do we give
them the best experience for online
sports betting igaming how to give them
a great experience for merchandise nfts
trading cards over time potentially live
sports um ticketing so we see this
really as kind of a platform that they
can give sports fans globally you know
everything they want and give them a
better experience and everything we
think about is about how do we improve
the experience for the fans michael
rubin here on the rich hasn't show look
i i know you already own a piece of the
sixers um but what do you mean by live
sports what do you mean by that you know
you know fanatics is going to
start a league or whatever
i think when we think about you know um
today we have you know close to 100
million sports fans and over time we'd
like to have billions of sports fans
that um you know come to fanatics for
all the digital sports needs one of
those things could be streaming live
sports and we think that you know that's
something long term that's very
interesting to us certainly very
competitive business today but we think
about as a sports fan comes to you know
fanatics how do we give them so many
things they want in one place and really
improve the experience as a result of
that so we think long term it's it's
really interesting for us we think about
media as an interesting long-term
business for ourselves what are you
going to start a sports network or
something like that yeah look i think
you know you've seen us get into the
trading card business from scratch
you've seen us get into the nft business
from scratch you've seen us um get into
the online sports betting night gaming
business from scratch and i think over
time media something definitely fits
well for us so you know on the other
side we're doing a lot today and we
recognize that we grew up in the in the
merchandise business and that business
is still growing very quickly as we
continue to grow the market but each of
these new businesses are helping the
other businesses strengthen and kind of
do more for the fan now so i'm just like
kind of workshopping it here so like
let's do it programs bro programs like
shoulder programming for your
merchandise or for your other digital
businesses and using the conversation of
sports or maybe even
showing a live sport to somebody
yeah long term that makes that
absolutely yeah that makes sense for us
well you're listening about sports you
want that hat you want that shirt you
want that yes
someone could be watching you know a
game in the city and they could say hey
i want to bet on that game i want to buy
that jersey i want to um you know i want
to watch that media i want to hey you
know what i want to go to a game i want
to get a ticket to that game right hey i
want an nft that great play that just
happened i want a trading card make to
order so all these things go together
and that's been the really interesting
thing is fanatics really has advantages
they give give to the fan is
when you can put these things together
in one place you can really improve the
experience and long term our vision is
you're gonna go to one kind of super
apple sports you're gonna be able to do
so many different things from fanatics
and in everything we do we're gonna say
how do we do it better for the fan how
do we improve it like i'll give you an
example today sir we're building
regional distribution centers you know
throughout the country to figure out how
do we get the merchandise to fans more
quickly how do we you know make better
products how do we you know keep
expanding the market and that's the
things that we think about in every
business that we get into so uh where do
you think again uh the executive
chairman and founder of fanatics michael
rubin right here on the rich eisen show
so uh how do you see you mentioned it
like i think three four times already
sports gambling how do you see the
advent
of of it being more prevalent now uh
there's i think three different
sports uh
betting partners of the nfl words i
never thought i would ever say into a
microphone let alone existing how do you
see this um manifesting further yeah
look i think if you look globally online
sports betting and and you know other
forms of gambling online are enormous
business i think they're um good
businesses globally and i think you know
we're very early in in america and in
north america and i think um this will
be a big business here the same way it
is other places in the world i think
long term it's going to be a a a big
business and eventually a good business
today you know economically it's still a
tough business for the operators in the
near term but i think it's going to be a
you know something that that you know at
the end of the day sports fans want to
do and so if we just think about it
strictly from the fans perspective which
is the way i like to think um you know
fans want to bet on sports they want to
do it the right way and they want to do
it in the best experience and to us the
ability to bundle a bunch of these
products together is going to give us a
huge you know advantage to best service
serve the fan which sport that you're
most closely involved with is the at the
forefront of this do you think or is
more open to
it
i think all sports are open to it to be
honest and you know you kind of you know
said you never thought you'd say those
words in the microphone i always thought
you would um
yeah 100 and i would have told you that
ten years ago you've been kicked out of
haru you know in two things i've been
kicking out of a lot of places they've
had good judgment for kicking me outside
nfl like in 2001 i want to talk sports
gambling yeah but sometimes you just
gotta be patient wait you know today i
think i'm still a kid i'm really not i'm
49 now but i'm going to be at this
another you know 30 40 years like i said
as long as i'm on this planet i think
you know markets evolve markets grow
it's our job to think about where's the
world going not you know in a quarter or
a year but where's it going five years
from now 10 years from now 20 years from
now you know sports gambling's you know
it's it's great for sports and that so
long as fans do it responsibly it's
something that fans want to do and it's
also it better engages with you know our
favorite players our favorite teams and
you know i think it brings more
excitement to the sports business
michael rubin here on the rich eisen
show so i guess what else is exciting
you like what else is on your mind
super bowl week as you're out here what
else is going on with you thank you
listen for me i start with i'm excited
every day when i wake up i'm one of the
worst sleepers in the world i went to
bed last night about 11 o'clock i woke
up at 2 45 i said please let me go back
to bed tonight tonight's not gonna be
able to fall back asleep would you look
at your phone is that what you did i
started sending emails text messages
responding to stuff oh my god i never
went back to bed and so you know i wake
up every day passionate about what i'm
doing i'm having a blast i mean for me i
think i'm one of the luckiest people in
the world to be able to to build it you
know what i hope can be one of the
biggest technology companies one of the
biggest companies in sport and you know
do it you know around so many you know
look at the end of the day without the
incredible sports properties we work
with the leagues the teams the players
players associations the universities
we're nothing so i feel really fortunate
to be leading this company and you know
you know what what am i thinking about i
keep thinking about two things yes how
do we
best service the fan number one and
number two
what are the new things we can do to
kind of add incremental value to the fan
and so that's beyond exciting i mean you
know i was kind of focused on all my
energy for the first ten years about how
to invade the merchandise business and
now we're thinking about how to do this
across so many different digital sports
businesses and it's fun it's great it's
like you wake up exciting you're
passionate when you're so excited you
can't even sleep that's a pretty good
thing right um and so um you got the nfl
merchandise business the fanatic super
bowl party is uh
is on saturday at two eastern time i
mean at two p.m route here pretty much
you got that guy it is yeah i'm gonna
check my phone off i'm sorry about three
days ago because i get about a hundred
uh text messages a day from people
trying to come to the party oh i thought
i thought you said from daryl mori i
thought that would be no no i got that
joke well but no okay very good yeah
um
so you know parties actually we do have
you know we think we have the best part
of super bowl weekend and so it's always
a blast the stallion megan sally is
performing um you got several great
performers um
dozier cat little baby um all you know
incredible uh people at the top of their
career and you know and you know just
incredible performance but you know for
us what our party's about is about
bringing people together that are really
important you know we've never you know
we all sell tickets or sponsorships or
anything this is just all about bringing
the people that are most important to
fanatics together all in one place and
there's so many people like look we
realize how fortunate and lucky we are
to work in this industry so we want to
you know do something to just kind of
bring all the special people together in
one place so it's always a fun party you
know unfortunately we couldn't do it
last year because of covet we did it
miami it was pretty uh it was a pretty
great event and we're looking forward to
it again i just i'm gonna um i think
i've for anyone who's who i know my
number's changed i have a new number
i'll resume that number again uh
saturday about seven o'clock i like that
and then what's the latest on the
reformer lines what do you got from me
formerlite's making great progress you
know for everyone who doesn't know the
story you know we started that one you
know one of my really close friends meek
mill uh went to prison for something i
didn't know you could go to prison for
which was not committing the crime and
uh i watched this happen in front of my
eyes in late 2017 where he had popped a
wheel in a motorcycle and and um he got
a traffic ticket that turned into going
to jail for two to four years because
there was a probation violation so we've
now you know as soon as he got out of
prison we put together an incredible
group of people robert kraft uh uh
clarissa robert smith jay-z
meek um mike novogratz uh lauren john
arnold just incredible group group
people who are fan of this organization
um we've had some great people put big
money behind jack dorsey who's been an
incredible donor to this we probably
raised close to 100 million dollars now
we're focused on doing really two things
yes one is on
changing the laws on a state-by-state
basis that don't allow people to go to
prison who don't commit crimes and
something that people will never
understand
twenty-five percent of the people that
go to prison each year
don't commit a crime
okay they go for technical violations
that means someone showed up late for a
probation meeting or this someone
couldn't make a probation meeting or um
you know they tested positive for
smoking marijuana and so when i watched
this happen to one of my close friends
you know robert kraft jay-z myself meek
we're like we got to do something about
this so we've now changed laws in in
more than a dozen states we've helped
get more than half a million people that
shouldn't be in the system uh off of
probation out of prison not on probation
any longer so we're really committed to
fixing the underlying laws for me when
you see a problem i don't want to fix it
you know kind of person by person i want
to fix the underlying systemic issue and
that's what the former alliance is all
about the other thing we're focused on
is educating people like if i said to
you hey rich would you believe that 25
of people that went to prison
each year didn't actually commit a crime
what would you say to me i would say i
believed it unfortunately that by the
way so i appreciate you telling me
that's not the normal answer i think
people that are affected by the criminal
justice system they usually understand
it that's about a quarter of the country
right another 75 percent who haven't you
know had someone involved they don't get
it all i didn't get it all and i was
people like you know why'd you get
interest i only got into it because i
watched with my friend friend yeah and i
had had not i would have never done
anything about it but you know i think
when things happen you gotta you know
you gotta like things happen for a
reason you know meek went to prison you
know four different times for not
committing a crime and you know now you
know his you know his case was finally
you know you know taken out of court you
know it's he's no longer on probation he
doesn't have to get his permission he
used to have to call to get permission
pick his kid up at school literally he
lived in in downtown philadelphia his
son lived 10 minutes across the
bridge in new jersey he couldn't pick
his son up without getting permission
from the court when he called they'd say
no you can't pick your kid up from
literally 10 minutes away so um you know
i'm proud of the work we're doing we
have a great ceo robert rooks who's done
an amazing job and you know we're
focused on like i said educating people
and changing laws
well uh reform alliance obviously
fanatics we all we all know about that
as well and everybody should uh you know
just not reach out to you for tickets to
your party but that's they can i'll call
you
you know i heard i i heard you're a
great source of information there you go
good okay yeah i mean plus three
yeah well
who do you love them hold on if you had
to pick others
if you had to pick who you love the most
he's he sat in the commissioner's box no
no no no no no no no who do you love the
most like me of these guys you're
talking about everyone here
oh we're gonna let you play pick your
favorite oh my god this is a start bench
cut right here yeah let's do it
which one do you love the most
we love you mikey
we'll get that person to the party with
you okay very good i can't believe you
don't choose
i can't they're all my babies they're
all my babies michael maybe i'll ask
maybe i'll hit up mattress and ask if he
can maybe slide me in he's got no juice
by the way yeah he's trying to drop the
names
uh okay uh michael and i just i'll say
it on the air you are so generous for
the run every year for saint jude
children's research hospital you help
elevate it you and mark luery together
um elevate this thing to uh to heights
that um you know i i'm very humbled by
and i greatly appreciate it so always so
thank you but i got to tell you
something i thank you because you're the
one who's doing a lot of work it's
always it's easy to be a check writer
it's hard to do the work and the one who
does the work deserves all the credit
thanks bro i can tell you i've learned
that with the reform alliance we work
hard on that and that's you know that's
what we put our blood sweat and tears
into but you know what you're doing with
that i know how passionate you are about
i know how much you hustle i know how
many people tell me about it each year
so congrats to what you're doing it's
it's it's it's it's truly incredible
thank you i appreciate that especially
since i do unfortunately put literal
blood sweat and tears into the run
that's my problem you know yeah now the
portrait thing is by the way you haven't
got me out there yet because i didn't
want you to see somebody who they do you
want to run do you run no i'm actually
terrified of it i would not want to
publicly humiliate myself
i'll race you on one condition all right
what's that you go on one foot you have
to hobble yeah how about your feet
i think that's fair yeah
that's the way i run with two feet
unfortunately same that's why i just
felt like you're training for it i'm
gonna do it like you know with like 10
seconds notice so at my old age i don't
want to take an injury so i think one
leg two legs feel like we're we're both
you know uh new year yeah i'm a new york
jew you're from philadelphia right and i
realized that uh in order for me to
succeed in the sports world i needed to
talk about it you needed to build a
company and that's that's no other way
to win
that's why we don't get it right but at
any rate thank you for everything you do
with the run really appreciate it
everybody follow michael rubin at
michael rubin on twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here